d'
accord,
alors
ensuite,
plus de ces trucs,
c'est peut-être sa place ici
oh voici un peter ouais il y a un gars qui
récolte du maïs ou quelque chose qui
enregistre
de ce côté ça a l'air sympa en
fait
pouvez-vous juste faire un cercle jim avant d'
atterrir ouais où  est la moissonneuse oh
il est sur ma gauche à trois heures oh d'accord
je l'ai amené ici d'accord juste une
machine en marche ouais oops juste une photo
de celle-là ouais d'
accord
ça va être cool
ouais eh bien ouais
il va probablement
les papillons dedans  l'herbe d'
accord ouais d'accord devrions-nous aller atterrir ou
quelque chose voulez-vous continuer ici
désolé je pense que nous en avons assez d'arrêter d'
enregistrer